there is an historic labor showdown
taking place in alabama involving the
world's largest online retailer
and now it's drawing the attention of
the white house thousands of workers at
an amazon warehouse
outside of birmingham are voting on
whether to form the company's
first labor union in the u.s this is an
historic challenge to the internet giant
at a time when amazon is hiring tens of
thousands of people every month
amazon is pushing its employees to vote
no but in a video message president
biden is urging management to back
off and let the workers decide for
themselves
nancy cordes is at the white house with
more on this story nancy good morning to
you why is this so significant
good morning gayle it's significant
because while many democrats are
pro-union
presidents from both parties typically
steer clear
of specific labor disputes particularly
when they involve one of the nation's
largest companies
the choice to join a union is
up to the workers full stop
in the two-minute video there was only
one state president biden mentioned
by name workers in alabama and all
across america are voting in whether to
organize a union
in their workplace bessemer alabama is
home to an
amazon warehouse where about 6 000
employees are voting right now
on whether to form the internet giant's
first union in the u.s
it's a bitter battle amazon doesn't
treat their employees
like people we're treated like we're
robots
warehouse employees like jennifer bates
constantly
get texts from amazon warning that union
dues
could leave them with less money than
they already have
anti-union flyers are even posted inside
warehouse bathroom stalls there should
be no intimidation
no coercion no threats no anti-union
propaganda
amazon didn't respond to our request for
comment
but in a previous statement to reuters
it said
we don't believe the union represents
the majority of our employees views
our employees chose to work at amazon
because we offer some of the best jobs
available
but more than 2 000 workers indicated
that they were
interested in joining a union which is
what triggered this vote
the white house insists the president
was simply showing support
for all unions we don't comment on
specific cases
but union officials say his message was
clear
for the workers at the warehouse in
alabama
there was no question that president
biden was speaking to
them stuart applebaum is the president
of the retail wholesale
and department store union the
importance of the video
is that it's telling workers that no
matter
how much your employer is trying to
intimidate you
no matter how powerful your employer may
be
the president of the united states has
your back
presidents traditionally take pains not
to wade into union disputes
but mr biden campaigned on a very clear
platform
i made it clear to the corporate leaders
i said i want you know i'm a union guy
one important note on the timing of all
this this is the week when the
president's proposed minimum
wage hike is officially falling apart on
capitol hill at least for now and he is
facing
some frustration from progressives who
wanted him to fight harder
so it may be part of the reason why he
chose to come out and show solidarity
with workers
to remind them that he's on their side
anthony
very interesting battle in alabama nancy
thank you